[Music]  hey everyone welcome to harry potter  theory what you're about to see is the  japanese version of the secrets of  dumbledore trailer which includes some  extra scenes not seen in the north  american version of the trailer comment  down below the extra scenes and what you  think of them  [Music]  harry potter  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  with or without you i'll burn down their  world  no  if we don't stop it  always with the spinning shaker you  brilliant man you know me pal i can't  pass up a good poor kid  to save our world each of us has a role  all of us are still alive  we should consider our efforts a success  correct three points to hufflepuff  he's not here for you he's here for me  i do  [Music]  you believe this place they've got  pint-sized little witches and wizards  running around here